якось мені зробили комплімент А ти
симпатична Як для
єврейкизму значно більше ніж люди собі
зазвичай уявляють
Анна дослідниця онкозахворювань у
Мюнхені а Дорн суддя у Берліні якщо для
інших антисемітизм газетних заголовок
для них це повсякдення дискримінація
лише тому що вони євреї
це актуальна реальна проблема вона
нікуди не поділася
від натяків до відкритого насильства
антисемітизм має багато проявів і часом
виявляєш його в самому собі мимохідь не
обов'язково треба мати злий намір щоб
сказати щось антисемітське
антисемітизм чому так складно його
подолати як віднесла себе до
ліберального юдаїзму наша громада
орієнтується на традиції був у нас тут
яскравий випадок це коли хтось їздив
велосипедом та мотоциклом навколо
синагоги і кричав Гай Гітлер у той час
коли дітей відводять до дитячого садка
тобто у 8:30 ранку Коли Тут збирається
багато батьків а потім мені видали на
одній вечірці одну Гітлер забув чи що
як самопроголошений фюрер Нацистської
Німеччини Адольф Гітлер відповідальний
за систематичне вбивство шести мільйонів
євреїв як поводитися в такій ситуації
єврейці чи іврию Ну я спочатку
розгубилася
у мене якось була зустріч і йшлося про
репортаж для одного відомого німецького
журналу і вже наприкінці за чашкою кави
зовсім неочікуване питання Ну а тепер
якщо чесно у євреїв завжди все крутиться
навколо грошей хіба ні І я подумав
Секунду мені точно Це почалося
і це лише один з багатьох вікових
забобонів адже
антисемітські стереотипи далеко не нові
вони спливають знову і знову одні й ті ж
потворні історії лише у новій упаковці
[музика]
існує безліч різних варіантів
антисемітизму Мер'єм венсель директорка
єврейського музею у Франкфурті То звідки
ж узялося кліше про нібито багатство
євреїв
історично так склалося що євреїв у
Європі не мали доступу до багатьох
професій водночас їм можна було
займатися торгівлею монетами та обміном
грошей уявлення про те що євреї завжди
пов'язані з грошима зародилося в
початковий період епохи нового часу
[музика]
особливо плідний ґрунт для
антисемійських стереотипів з'являється у
кризові часи напевно найвідоміша
антисимістська Теорія змови це так звана
невидима рука ви не можете її побачити
вона невидима але є припущення що це
щось моторошне що працює таємно
професор історії колумбійського
університету Джорджа Вашингтона
навіть під час пандемії коронавірусу цю
теорію змови знову розганяли ці питання
про те кому що вигідний ковід а потім
натяки що це ж мова євреїв бізнесменів
та компанії які виробляють вакцини і так
далі І так далі
невелика група людей які потай правлять
світом доволі зручне для багатьох
уявлення з давньою традицією
[музика]
Це звісно головний антисемітський
наратив
і він християнський
чутки про невидиму руку ходять ще з
часів середньовіччя християни тоді
хотіли поширити свою релігію по всій
Європі і переслідували євреїв
а це означає що Теорія змови про те що
євреї роблять щось таємно завжди
мобілізує емоції які потім у свою чергу
призводять до актів насильства
Особисто я стикаюся з цим дуже часто і
мені просто цікаво що говорять німці
коли заходить мова про антисемітські
теорії змови чи мовчать вони чи все ж
таки щось говорять
так говорити про це варто адже
ігнорування антисемітизму не означає що
його немає
Але чому саме німцям так важко
розбиратися з антисемітизмом можливо
тому що вони думають що успішно
розпрощалися з ним у минулому
Мені здається що багато хто пов'язує
антисемітизм виключно з другою світовою
та уявленням що антисемітизм винайшов
гітлерів все закінчилося 45-го року але
це зовсім не відповідає історії
Якщо коротко антисемітизм розпочався не
з нацистів
ба більше євреї піддавалися
систематичним переслідуванням
насильницькому навернення до інших
релігій та вигнанню протягом століть
проте нацистка диктатура була
безпрецедентно жорстокою з приходом до
влади Гітлера 1933-му євреїв у Німеччині
дедалі більше виключали із суспільного
життя шляхом антисемітських законів
антисемітська Пропаганда взагалі не
вважала євреїв людьми у Німеччині та
окупованій нацистами Європі євреїв
замикали у гетто та депортували до
концентраційних таборів катували та
систематично вбивали
якщо ми дійсно хочемо боротися з
антисемітизмом не варто завжди
використовувати голокост як стандарт для
порівняння
ми радше маємо уважно придивитися А як
проявляється дискримінація у
повсякденному житті що це за маленькі
мовні обороти ментальні упередження які
далеко не одразу означають вбивство
можна вважати лише того хто виступає за
відправку євреїв до газових камер а все
що не заходить так да вже стає
легітимним Якщо коротко вбивство євреїв
екстремальна форма антисемітизму
однак виражатися він може й в такій
формі А ти симпатичний для єврейки але
що це означає у повсякденному житті ти
помічаєш це коли бабуся дає тобі мацу на
Песах ти кладеш її у машину а бабуся
каже Ні ніколи не клади на видноті
сховай Я не хочу щоб мій сусід помітив
що ми євреї У кулі моїх друзів багато
євреїв які відкрито не говорять про свою
етнічну чи релігійну приналежність тому
що вони стикалися з антисемітизмом для
мене це стрес постійно щось приховувати
і я завжди кажу відкрито про те що я
єврейка А якщо у когось виникають
проблеми із цим Вони мають просто
обговорити їх зі мною думаю реагувати
можна по-різному це так у залежить від
людини а іноді по-різному реагує навіть
та сама людина відчуття час діставати
валізи або на часі більш реально
оцінювати те що тут відбувається Чи можу
я дійсно бути частиною тутешнього
суспільства в довгостроковій перспективі
чи достатньої захищений куди це веде
місце де багато євреїв почуваються в
безпеці це Ізраїль єдина єврейська
держава світу
1950 року євреї з усього світу а також
нову навернення до юдаїзму мають право
жити в Ізраїлі та стати громадянами цієї
держави
для мене як віруючий єврейки має
значення що я там можу відкрити
відзначати єврейське свято
з одного боку це місце де можна
сховатися і відчуття що є така країна
з іншого боку просто можливість побути
там трохи і не відчувати що ти у
меншості
має велике значення для євреїв адже
навіть просто ходити вулицею зі своєю
зіркою Давида і знати що Нічого не
станеться це вже неймовірне почуття для
єврея чи єврейки
однак після заснування держави Ізраїль
виник новий різновид антисемітизму
антисемітизм щодо Ізраїлю
Та ж сумна картина спостерігається у
всьому світі якщо в заголовках газет
домінує близькосхідний конфлікт
кількість антисемітських нападів зростає
конфлікти щойно в Ізраїлі виникає
конфлікт настрій відразу стає більш
жорстким неприємними тут
мене завжди спантеличує що інші люди
коли я кажу що єврейка починають
критикувати мене за політикою Ізраїлю
або вважають мене відповідальною за неї
Я не маю ізраїльського паспорта я не
можу там голосувати я не можу вплинути
на політичну ситуацію там я не
ізраїльтянка
[музика]
більшість євреїв не є ізраїльтянами у
багатьох немає взагалі жодного зв'язку з
Ізраїлем
коли мене запитують що на твій погляд
відбувається зараз в Ізраїлі без
обвинувального тону І підтексту що ти і
твій народ знову коїти якщо просто
запитують як ти це оцінюєш то звичайно
відповідаю нормально але саме тон в
своїй визначає
а тому треба усвідомити що не всі євреї
відповідальні за політику Ізраїлю
звичайно критикувати ізраїльський уряд
можна але де межа між антисемітизмом і
політичними дебатами
якщо наприклад демонстрація проходить
перед синагогою а не перед посольством
Ізраїлю Грань уже починає стиратися
і це одна з головних проблем яка полягає
в тому що дуже часто критика політики
уряду Ізраїлю додатково ставить під
сумнів саме право на існування
єврейської держави
або інший типовий випадок коли від
євреїв автоматично очікують що вони
висловлюватимуться щодо Ізраїлю хочуть
вони цього чи ні ви за чи проти того то
І того-то до чого в лояльні і тут треба
чітко говорити це вже не на межі а
очевидний антисемітизм тому що в такому
разі люди виходять з того що кожен єврей
у певному сенсі є представником
ізраїльського уряду
тема на якій легко впектися але що
робити взагалі не говорити про уряд
Ізраїлю та його політику
саме тому я завжди трохи насторожено
ставляться до таких закидів про Ізраїль
взагалі говорити не можна звісно Ізраїль
близький нам і звичайно для більшості з
нас він важливіше ніж багато інших країн
і говорити про нього це абсолютно
нормально
Отже критика політики Ізраїлю - це
а от замішувати ізраїльську політику та
життя євреїв у всьому світі неправильно
і часто є антисемітизмом завдяки
соціальними мережам антисемітські
упередження В наші дні поширюється
Буквально за лічені секунди
це як дрібний шрифт на кожній упаковці
продуктів харчування читайте його уважно
тільки Тому що фейсбуку чим деінде щось
стверджується а інші це повторюють це ще
не є правильним На жаль часто навпаки
Тож як завжди не вірте всьому що чуєте
чи читаєте
за антисемітизмом євреї стикаються у
всьому світі і це завжди одні й ті самі
стереотипи одні й ті самі упередження та
сама ненависть боротися із цим важко але
бути євреєм означає набагато більше
це можливо те що слід робити намагатися
робити фокус на поточний активне життя
єврейської громади і показувати що
відбувається насправді адже і для євреїв
завжди існує велика небезпека того що
вони можуть почати мислити виключно в
цих вимірах і забути про позитивні
сторони
я не уточнюю себе з роллю жертви Я
завжди відкрито ношу свою зірку Давида
пишаюся тим що я єврейка і вулицями
Мюнхена Я ходжу як горда єврейка
[музика]